blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
welcome everybody want to go through a
couple of clips i spotted over the last
week
bookmarked them didn't end up having
time to talk about these
um earlier in the week first one is of
everybody's best friend
former judge yeah and republican
congressman louis gomert
who i just don't know how this guy
manages to get himself to work every day
with the things he seems to believe and
be confused by
during a recent hearing
congressman louie gohmert asked
whether the bureau of land management
might be able to change the orbit of the
moon
in order to deal with climate change
uh once and for all um
let's take a look at this now the
premise is that the moon's orbit is
changing and that's true we know that
that's an absolutely true thing the moon
is slowly drifting away from earth
um at something like a 3.8 centimeters
per year
and that's something we've seen over the
last you know couple
few billion years or so and
um louie's idea is maybe
the forest management and bureau of land
management agencies
they could just change the moon's orbit
even further okay here's the uh here's
the clip and check out the reaction from
us
jennifer silberstein it's just perfect
and i understand
from what's been testified to the forest
service and the
blm you want very much to
work on the issue of climate change i
was
uh informed by the media past
director of nasa that they have found
that
the moon's orbit is changing slightly
and so is the earth's orbit around the
sun we know there's been a significant
solar flare
activity and so
is there anything that the national
forest service
or blm can do to
change the course of the moon's orbit
or the earth's orbit around the sun
obviously that would have profound
effects
on our climate
i would have to follow up with you on
that one mr gohmert
yeah well if you figure out a way that
you
in the uh forest service can make that
change
i'd like to know uh also just to
put on your radar that reaction is is
just
something else it's sort of you know
when
a kid says i want to make a dinosaur and
you say
yeah let's check that out uh jimmy
let's let's look into that that sounds
interesting this is
painfully dumb and this this is up there
like with
donald trump wanting to nuke a hurricane
or something like that like how do we
even analyze
this other than to say is it scarier
that this guy's currently a member of
congress
or is it scarier that this guy used to
be a judge
maybe member of congress because i don't
know what the rules are for judges in
texas but if they're just appointed
i don't know let me put it this way it's
an open question what's scarier that
this guy is a congressman or that he was
a judge
i would go even further i would say
don't have
the forest managers deal with this just
use that jewish space laser
that marjorie taylor green was talking
about and
you know louie's real mistake is it's
not bureau of land management
that's gonna change the orbit you've got
to talk to the department of housing and
urban development that's really who's
going to be able to get involved
and uh and change that lunar orbit just
wacky and bizarre stuff and this guy is
one of 435
elected members of congress he has one
of 435
privileged votes that determine
so much about the lives of everyday
americans not a good sign
for the country that's for sure you know
a lot has been made of how
the bush family they're more serious
republicans you know they don't support
trump
george w bush uh not a big trump guy
jeb bush seemingly not a big trump guy
but
in comes george p bush and he's just on
his knees
seemingly praying at the altar of trump
and i think i know what it is that's
going on here
um he sounds almost like q anon in this
interview
check this out where he says no no no
i'm my own man
and trump is great this this bush loves
trump take a look
and so when i talk about my record
whether it's as land commission or my
support of trump
you know i just stick to the facts the
fact is that in 2016 i was one of the
first statewide elected officials to
come out and support him
i raised a million and a half in support
of republican candidates with him at the
top of the ticket
it was a high water mark for republican
party politics in the state of texas and
in 2020
i boldly declared that trump was the
only thing standing between our country
the american people and socialism
and lo and behold i've turned out to be
correct with
over 30 trillion in total spending 6
trillion in just next year's
annual budget so yeah when you look at
my policies
i'm all about america first trump is the
center of the republican party
i'm my own man i support him and we need
to carry on that legacy capture the
lightning that he brought to the
republican party
so that we can help all of our fellow
republicans down ballot so through the
holiday season this year
you're the son of jeb bush the
conversations must be fascinating uh you
you're
very strong very uh distinct in your
support for the president
we know that many members of your family
do not like him
is there been any pressure on you what
is though do you not have those
conversations
how do you handle that well i think
we're just like any
american family and and that we have our
differences of opinion
whether it's with respect to president
trump whether it's respect to
hot button issues i i mean again it's
very similar to the type of stuff you
hear
at a trump rally right trump stopped
socialism in its tracks
and now biden is proof of how important
that was
out of this world sort of stuff and
what i would love to see asked as a
question here is
okay george p bush that's interesting do
since you support trump and you think
trump's great
was trump right when trump said
that your uncle george w bush lied us
into a pointless war with iraq would
george p
bush agree with that is trump the lord
and savior
on that particular question i think this
is
nothing other than obvious
brazen brown nosing for future help
from donald trump if indeed donald trump
is still in a position of power and what
i mean by that is
george p bush is running for texas
attorney general a texas
is almost certainly going to play a
major role in the future of american
politics maybe even in 2024
trump might be back in trump might be
the republican nominee in 2024.
trump being president or not could
depend on
texas and trump would absolutely
crush this guy if he doesn't get in line
that's fundamentally what's going on
here i don't even know
if george p bush really believes this
stuff like some part of me
is okay george p bush is so wacky that
he thinks trump is great that's terrible
that's a huge indictment of george p
bush
the other side is he's just a liar and
he's of the george w bush
jeb bush george h.w bush
mindset about trump but he's saying this
stuff because he thinks it will benefit
him in the future because he might need
to need trump's help or at least he
wants to avoid
trump's disdain either way it's vile
either the guy is an idiot or he's a
complete and total liar
and i don't know which is worse but um
it's it's not good not good is the way i
would describe it
make sure you're following me on twitter
let me know what you think about
george p bush does he believe this stuff
about trump
or is he simply trying to play towards
trump's support
at some point in the future when he
needs it i'm on twitter at deepakman let
me know
what a great program we have for you
today we'll take some of your calls next
we've had two weeks in a row of
beautiful calls i'm feeling pretty good
about a third week
and then much more coming up stay with
us
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to
blinkist.com slash david pakman i've put
the link
right underneath this video remember
that the david pakman show is mostly
funded by
members it is the much maligned
but never equaled world famous and
award-winning bonus show yeah i know
that there are awards we give out but
who cares
um join at joinpakman.com very easy we
do an extra show every day for our
members and it's just a good
time it's just a good time let's hear
from some people
via discord we used to take phone calls
via an actual phone line and it was a
disaster for a whole bunch of different
reasons
we now do it via discord it's a disaster
for completely different reasons and i
believe
preferable reasons you can find the
discord
at davidpakman.com discord that is the
place
um let's see what is on folks minds
today let's go to
uh oh you know what let's let's go to
our friend sabrina we haven't heard from
sabrina for so long what's going on
sabrina
it's sabrina sorry hey david can you
hear me okay
i i can hear you so well you must be
using a perfect phone
okay sorry about that i obviously
haven't had enough coffee this morning
uh thanks so much for taking my call as
you know i'm a long time
fan a long time viewer um i actually
wanted to ask you
what you think about the current race
for mayor in boston
i'm actually volunteering with michelle
wu and i know
a couple of people on the campaign that
work really closely with her
i think it'd be really cool for you to
have michelle lu on the show
do a little interview and talk about
what's on her mind
yeah the thing about mayor's races i
mean even
even like new york city city mayor
might rise to the level where it makes
sense for a show like ours where
most of our audience is not in any one
city so mayoral races are tough but
but new york city maybe boston is tough
i just don't know i i've i've not been
following it
super closely uh michelle wu
does follow me on twitter and she's
aware of the show she's in the universe
i know people
volunteering for a number of the
different candidates i i just don't know
sabrina if it's right for this show you
know
yeah i mean it's something i could
consider i think the campaign is
part of a larger trend of progressives
running all over
the country sure no that's a good point
you should really be doing pr because
see when when a publicist comes to me
they come to me and they say
sir here's my guest no one's ever heard
about to talk about some topic you're
not interested in and i'll say i don't
think it's
i don't see why it's good for our show a
good publicist will say
exactly what you just did which is no no
this is part of the story here is in
boston
the story is uh progressives right you
know
so you're you really may have a future
in pr sabrina
awesome so i'll keep pushing it if you
know things get better with the campaign
in the next couple months
yeah thanks so much for taking my call
david bye all right thanks sabrina uh
very very good um yeah no listen that's
that's a big job which is convincing
people on shows that what you're
pitching is actually
uh actually actually interesting why
don't we go
next to alex from
san diego alex you're on the air
wow hello i didn't actually expect to be
chosen um
so i have a quick i have a question for
you i've long thought that the most
important
issue in politics today is the impact
that money has on politics
and then if you solve that a lot of the
other issues would naturally solve
themselves over time
as people's natural instincts are very
reasonable
in general do you do you agree that this
is the most important issue or do you
see something else is the most important
issue today
i believe that there is a sort of
triumvirate
or a uh three-headed monster of sorts
that are really the three most important
uh
issues systemically and you hit on one
of them
money in politics is one aspect of this
uh
climate change is a sort of systemic and
structural issue
where if cities end up underwater
it's not going to really matter what our
opinion about abortion is so it's sort
of like whatever issue you care about if
we don't deal with climate change we're
not going to be able to to get that
fixed
and then thirdly would be uh how our
elections are
are run meaning that they're mostly
first
past the post and and for the presidency
it's an electoral college system so all
those three issues together
if we could fix campaign finance money
in politics if we could get to some kind
of
transferable vote and get rid of the
electoral college
and then if we could deal with climate
change then we would sort of be
set up to start dealing with like okay i
care about education here's how i'll
be an activist on education you might
care about
you know trans rights here's how you can
get involved in that i i think that you
are right
in identifying one of the three major
issues
see that that's kind of my point though
i feel like a lot of those other issues
can in many ways be reduced down to the
money and politics issue
like climate change for example if money
and poli
if money if there was some way to
resolve campaign finance
so then over time candidates would begin
to more accurately
represent the will of the people
hopefully ideally
and most people want to do something
about climate change yeah i don't
disagree
in in that you're say that over the long
term that we might get to some kind of
equilibrium
but it would be a long time because even
if you quote dealt with money in
politics
fossil fuels are still advantaged in a
number of different ways including by
the sheer market power that they have
in ways that are not directly connected
to money in politics so i'm with you
about the long term
i think if we wanted to more quickly do
something about it i would still put
these three issues sort of as the
the three-headed monster that needs to
be dealt with
i see very thank you for that um i have
one other very minor thing if you don't
train
um um the other thing is i've i've had
this idea
and i don't know if anyone else has
talked about it i've never heard it
talked about but
um it's related to like how to address
worker executive pay disparity
why in addition to also
being able to increase taxes on um
very wealthy people and you know and
wealth in general
um and i realized this idea may not may
be unpassable but nonetheless i want to
know what you think of it
sure why not tie the tax rate for
corporations to the app to the
difference between like the highest paid
executives and the median pay of the
company
such that the bigger that disparity the
more the company pays in some additional
tax and if they want to reduce that tax
they have to
improve average worker pay it's a super
interesting idea and so to give an
example the way it might work would be
uh if you um if the ceo
earns a hundred times more than the
lowest paid person
you pay a 12 corporate tax rate but if
the ceo earns a thousand times that of
the lowest paid person
your tax rate goes up to 40 something
like that right i mean not those numbers
but that's the idea
yeah i think it's super interesting i
think there's a couple problems one
is i don't know how something like that
even
comes close to passing but let's let's
ignore that right because we're talking
about whether it's a good idea
i think you still because the corporate
tax rate
first of all applies only to certain
businesses
any self-proprietorship llc s
corporation those are passed through so
the corporate tax rate doesn't even make
a difference to
them unless you deal with that and the
fact that you can still
deduct and loophole your way down to
zero tax liability you would need to
still combine it with an alternative
minimum tax for corporations
you'd have to do a bunch of other stuff
it's interesting
practically speaking i don't see any way
that it would pass in the next
20 years but i think it's a really
interesting idea
okay thank you for that dude that's all
i have keep up all right good work thank
you very much
uh guys the the this is week three of
really strong phone calls
really really strong phone calls not
going to lie i'm uh we we've really
kind of hit a uh hit our stride i guess
i would say
let's go to chandler from indianapolis
chandler from indianapolis you're on the
air
uh hello can you hear me yes i can
hey david uh first time colin long time
listener hate to be that cliche
thank you but um yeah so i just have a
question about covet in general so um i
live in indianapolis
and um just recently the mask mandate
was lifted for the city
uh city county council lifted it on uh
monday night and something that really
concerns me
is that the percentage of the people who
live in the city
um who have gotten the vaccine at least
like one shot
is only like i think i think it's like
36 percentage
uh you know less than 40 percent yikes
um
i'm not really sure uh what you would
think
for or what what let me let me just
rephrase this so
what would you think would be a
reasonable percentage
for a mass mandate to be lifted for a
city
um you know like the size of
indianapolis i don't know how it is with
boston
or how it is up there
yeah i don't you know the i'm not an
epidemiologist or an immunologist so so
basically i'm going by what i've read
those experts say but it seems
quite reasonable to me that as you
approach
50 percent um uh
immunized that certainly masks can start
coming off and we're seeing masks come
off in most places and things seem to be
more or less going okay
among the vaccinated the unvaccinated
are seeing
increased hospitalizations in some
places like in tennessee
but uh yeah i mean i think at 50 you can
start to to really do a lot of things
oh yeah for sure i i would definitely
agree
and honestly at this point of the
pandemic i would believe that
you know some things are kind of common
sense like if you're gonna go to walmart
i would probably wear a mask uh
if um you were to go out to a park you
know
don't wear a mask unless there's like a
crowd for whatever reason yeah so
right i think that common sense would
definitely
be
kind of what we all need to be uh
listening for yeah and remember that the
cdc has said that once you are
vaccinated
essentially every activity is low risk
without a mask but certainly if there's
a situation in which you still would be
more comfortable with a mask
i say wear it why not yeah oh yeah for
sure
um yeah and um let me see well that's
all great i'm going to let you go
because we have so many people but
that's a great question and i'm
hopefully things will continue to
improve in indianapolis
i appreciate you uh taking the call uh
all right keep on doing what you're
doing man
very good thank you so much let's take a
really quick break if you're holding
don't hang up
because we are taking more calls
momentarily stay with us
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive of
every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's go back to the discord
lines and hear from some more folks you
can find the david pakman show discord
at davidpakman.com slash discord
of course why don't we talk to
um oh you know what you know who's on a
new grongler from california is here
crossover caller from the majority
report and
other shows that some may be aware with
uh aware of
new what is going on oh hello david
hello so i'm not gonna
bring up that thing you told me not to
bring up
before you started recording okay so
let me begin by not bringing that up now
right
so i like you know as you've mentioned
i've been getting
radicalized over at friends of the set
the majority report
with sam cedar and they have assessed
that
the friendly language of democratic
party leadership
like biden and pelosi towards
republicans yeah is a significant part
of what let republicans gain seats in
the house recently
saying things like we need republicans
republicans will come around
after trump is gone et cetera and you
know i've i've had enough i think it's
time for
the democratic party to start trash
talking these clowns
you see what i mean by radicalization
but anyways sure
let's not forget that the trump admin
didn't want to do stimulus checks at
first
calling them bailouts of democrat-run
cities
right so i ask you know is it time or
is it risky because i guess mansion
would be even less cooperative
i don't know that i understand the
question is the question about the
rhetoric towards republicans or the
discussions within democrats
uh no the rhetoric towards republicans
like should
democratic politicians start you know
kind of just
abandoning um
you know this kind of friendly attitude
towards bipartisanship
yeah okay i understand it okay so this
is a good question listen here's here's
my thought on this and i even talked
about this earlier in the week to some
extent
i think it's good to say you would
rather
get something done with republicans than
without them i think that that's a great
thing to say
why not right let's if we can if we can
do something with republicans without
compromising our values let's do it with
republicans
i think it's great to involve
republicans in the conversation when i
read that joe biden has had
this or that republican at the white
house and they talked about this and
they talked about
that's fantastic but you've got to know
when to cut it off and so now we have
reports for example that the
negotiations with biden and republicans
on the infrastructure bill
are now done because republicans you
know biden sliced a trillion dollars off
and republicans came up 150 billion it's
like come on guys
that that's not going to go anywhere so
you just cut it off
and uh the the problem for democrats
is twofold number one now there's like a
moderate group of democrats and
republicans negotiating the
infrastructure bill
i don't know that something that gets
negotiated by moderate democrats and
republicans
actually gets 60 votes in the senate i
think you end up if you're on the on the
democratic side
your only option will end up being
budget reconciliation and that's
if you can get 50 votes and then it
becomes a matter of can you convince joe
manchin can you convince
kirsten cinema so i don't have a problem
with the talk of bipartisanship i don't
have a problem with negotiations i don't
have a problem with involving
republicans
but at a certain point you have to cut
it off and you have to say we're doing
it our way and we're just going to do it
the problem is if you only have 49 votes
in the senate then you can't do it and
that's where joe manchin gets all of his
power from
yeah it's uh kind of bleak it's bleak
i'm not gonna lie but listen
we still have memes right we at least
have that
we we do that's true um i i should uh i
should get started on some of those too
i have some ideas
please please i think that that would
bring a nice positive energy to the show
all right you know what the means i am
waiting for though is uh
when the elections get close and
the means last year of uh i don't know
something important and then
it cuts off to you saying doesn't matter
we need to get out and vote everybody's
right
we're going to get back to that we're
going to get back to that all right
thank you for the call my friend
thank you all right there we go uh noog
wrangler there let's go next to
oh there's some interesting folks here
some interesting folks
let's go to i'm going to pronounce it
correctly this time
nisha from michigan did i get it right
nisha
yes david you got it right thank you
what's going on
um not that much um i actually
um did talk to uh my friend um that i
talked to you about um
i guess the last time that i was on yeah
it was like a pretty it was like a
trumpist but not a super crazy one is
that right
yeah she's well she's definitely not a
trumpist or anything like that
um she just just doesn't really like um
she doesn't really trust um the um
you know the the vaccine and whatnot oh
it was the vaccine okay all right fair
enough okay
vaccine got it we kind of had a bit of a
falling out
really am i responsible for it
no no no you're not okay because i
told her that um a friend of mine and
another friend of mine and her mother
they were fully vaccinated and i was
actually able to let them see
um my child right and
once uh i think once i told her that i
think she kind of got very defensive and
then she asked me why did i
get the vaccine because now i'm fully
vaccinated
right so i pretty much of course had to
go and tell her like the reason why i
got
my vaccination was because to protect
my daughter and whatnot and also my
husband also got the same thing as well
yep so i've tried to not get into a
debate with her because
she was asking me so many questions and
then she was bombarding me with all this
stuff and she was even telling me
of course with her um whatever type of
resources she
had and i was like well where's your
well where's your proof and
what where's your proof and whatnot it
was like well i don't know where'd you
get your stuff i
read my stuff so
right i i just couldn't really oh man
and then i had to go and ask my husband
to pretty much help me out because she
kept on saying that um
the vaccine was pretty much done in like
in a matter of months
and i pretty much had to go and tell
like it wasn't really in a matter of
months it pretty much took uh over a
decade
right yeah i think my approach to when
people say that is
you know sequencing the virus is a
matter of a few hours
what the point here with these mrna
vaccines is the underlying technology
and that's been researched for more than
a decade sequencing the virus is child's
play and it can be done in just a matter
of hours but that
that this is a different type of vaccine
and so just applying that kind of
statement doesn't really make sense
because the underlying technology's been
in development for so long
all right and because i think my husband
has said that
um i think it's i think they started
doing it i think back in 2003
so pretty much uh almost i guess close
to two decades i i i may be wrong
yeah but nisha so are you guys not no
longer speaking because of the vaccine
differences of opinion uh pretty much
his differences of opinion she
she of course told me that her sister
was of course getting the vaccine and
her mother was
two yeah and she also she was
infected with covid um i think
maybe maybe three weeks ago so she
finally of course got out of it
yeah and i was pretty much thinking like
don't you think that would at least
gotten a reason well
then a reason for you to at least take
the vaccine just so you don't get sick
anymore
right because i kind of had some type of
some type of
epiphany like if you keep on getting
sick from the same
virus over and over again it might i
don't know i
could be wrong that it might damage you
in some type of way to where you can't
really recover from it
well once you recover you're protected
from that strain for some period of time
but it's not as robust protection as
from
uh as from getting vaccinated yeah well
listen
um hopefully the relationship can be uh
reconvened and
rehabilitated and i really appreciate
you giving me the update nisha
okay all right thanks very much
all right there is nisha from michigan
with an
update there let's go next to emil
from maryland emil from maryland you're
on the air
hey david thanks for pronouncing my name
correctly my pleasure um
i wanted to ask you have you been
following
or have you heard about the ongoing
situation in ethiopia
not not if there's anything recent i
mean generally speaking i've been
following ethiopia for for 10 years but
what's going on right now
the well the the the tigre
crisis the civil war going on in the
northern region that
has started in november you've heard
about that yes yes yes
okay i was curious what what is the
sort of the narrative i guess that that
you've heard about it and
uh well i haven't really seen you
covered much on your show i'm just
curious why you have it
yeah i just i just don't know enough
about it you know one of the things i
try not to do on this show
that i just don't know enough about i'm
i'm not the right person to give you any
kind of hot take or or analysis of it
i haven't covered it because i don't
know enough about it i've been so busy
with other things so i just i don't want
to comment on things i don't know about
okay yeah no i i understand that and i
respect that i just wanted to say that
the the situation is really complicated
in general there's they're trying you
know
there are some people who have an
interest in putting out a genocide
narrative
and yeah i just think that's really
inconclusive at this time there needs to
be an investigation on
the atrocities that are happening
because they definitely are happening
there
there are some war crimes going on but i
just really hope that
uh the the us and the
administration doesn't pull some kind of
libya or syria type of uh intervention
and that i just think that
would be a really bad disaster and
really destabilize the region
all right well let me read up on it and
i'll follow up if i have some uh
something to add
okay cool yeah well yeah like i i just
want to say
a lot of the stuff that is in the
western media is
i feel like a little biased and from
what i'm hearing from like internally in
the country it's
it's just a really complicated situation
and i feel like it's just me a while
before we really know like what's
what's actually going on that applies to
most conflicts that the perspective from
western media
is relatively narrow and rarely does any
perspective fully tell us
really what's going on in the country i
think that that's we should bring that
approach to our understanding of most
issues this it's kind of made me rethink
a little bit the
uh you know israel-palestine conflict
because
i i can kind of see how things can get
uh can get distorted
if you don't understand the history but
um i just think
most people should be a little agnostic
on the situation
we'll learn more in the time coming
there's they're having a big election
next month
and you know we'll we'll see how things
unfold after that all right emil thank
you
yeah thanks david all right uh there is
a meal from maryland
uh why don't we go next over to
[Music]
let's go to jaron from atlanta jaron
you're on the air
hey david thank you so much for having
me on
my pleasure i wanted to ask about
what you thought of the job that janet
yellen has been doing especially with
this new uh
deal the world corporate global tax
minimum i wanted to know what you
thought about that
yeah i mean my general take on yellen so
far is she's she's been
predictable we had a sense you know when
she was selected by joe biden there were
some on the left who said
this is another neo-liberal centrist and
you know i took the time of digging into
papers she's written and work that she's
done
and she's definitely you know she she
she's definitely not a socialist right
which is no surprise
neither is joe biden but her
perspectives
are um sort of as left as one might
imagine a mainline democratic president
would have uh when it comes to her
outlook
on inflation and interest rates it's
been sort of unremarkable but
i'm i'm basically with her about it's
really too soon to make any
uh serious decisions or have any serious
sense of uh the direction that inflation
is going as far as the global wealth tax
i saw the proposal some period of time
did something new happen in the last
week that i missed with it
uh i haven't seen anything about that i
just saw the g7 deal
i think it's an interesting idea and and
for people who don't know the
the point of of some of this is if you
can get countries to come together
and say all of us are going to agree
that individuals cannot avoid
taxes in one member country
by shifting income to another member
country
and we want a base minimum level of
global tax
that is going to be paid i think it's an
interesting idea
i see it very difficult to enforce
and it's one of those things where i i
would really want to know the details of
how they're proposing it be done
um and then where would disputes be
adjudicated related to it like there's
questions which maybe have been answered
and i haven't looked into it enough yet
i think it's super interesting i don't
know how you really get it done
yeah um i think it's great that she's
starting to hold
uh and as well as the other economic
leaders of the free world starting to
hold multinational corporations
accountable
yeah absolutely absolutely with that
being the end goal
is something i'm completely behind the
implementation and how you get it done
is where i
where i'd want to know more and also
just
one quick thing uh for the future
outlook of yellen um
do you think she'll be able to do a good
job of managing inflation as we get out
of this pandemic
phase you know i do think so um
i mean i i think she seems to understand
that the numbers from march and april
really don't tell us what we need to
know to come up with a comprehensive and
more reliable
outlook um i have every confidence that
she has the knowledge and experience
to successfully manage inflation i have
no real concern right now
well yeah thank you that's really great
insight uh i'm
i'm just a high schooler i took an
economics class no way
a political class and it's this stuff
really interests me so i really
appreciate uh you taking the time
brilliant all right thank you for the
cauldron thank you so much
all right wow jiron in high school would
not have guessed that
uh from the uh from the questions that
were coming in
okay let's continue uh who do we want to
speak to next oh i don't know
there's just so many possibilities here
how about
a josh from rhode island rhode island
not a state heavily represented during
live calls josh
uh can you hear me yes i can hell nice
speaking with you
um my question has to do with uh
unemployment
so uh recently i saw that uh they
changed unemployment to where you have
to be uh looking for a job again like
you have to be
actively doing that yes and i was
wondering because i hear all the time
people uh they'll say that oh everyone
just wants to be on unemployment
and then when i say that now they have
to be looking for a job i hear
you know people can just uh they just
apply to like i think it's like three
jobs a week
and then don't do anything else and then
just collect their check so i kind of
my question is kind of in two parts
first is people
i hear that a lot but it's actually that
easy to just like
apply to a few places and then get money
without having to do anything
and part two are people actually doing
that because
uh from conservatives i hear all the
time that like people don't want to work
and they'll just
you know apply to a job just to get
unemployment i
one note that's actually a thing that
happens so first of all in order to
initially qualify for unemployment you
actually have to be unemployed so in
normal circumstances you have to have
lost a job but not been fired for cause
right
and so first so just to qualify for
unemployment
some some barriers have to be some
threshold has to be met
is it as simple as applying to a few
jobs to continue receiving unemployment
it basically is yeah and it depends on
the state like for example
when i was in college i used to work for
the now defunct circuit city and when
they
switched from commission to hourly for
sales people they
laid off the top sales people one of
which i was
and so i got to collect unemployment
because my my position was eliminated
i had to go on and say i'm looking for a
job
i wasn't asked where did i apply it was
just have you been looking for a job
yes i have and then i would get the
money that system may have changed the
systems are different
in each state that is something that you
can do you apply for a few jobs
and then you continue collecting
unemployment i am not worried about this
and i've made a couple of clips
explaining why
but fundamentally um enhanced
unemployment ends in september
you are not allowed to be on
unemployment an indefinite amount of
time
many people many many people in the fall
are going to get to the end
of unemployment and at that point they
are going to stop receiving the benefits
so um they are either going to have to
figure out how to pay for their expenses
without making any money
or they're going to have to go and get
themselves a job so any any social
insurance program will have some free
riders or people who just do the minimum
in order to keep collecting the
unemployment
as long as the system big picture is
working and unemployment and enhanced
unemployment
saved so many people during the pandemic
i don't worry about a few free riders
they're going to lose their benefits
relatively soon anyway the benefits
don't last forever
all right thank you so just if a
conservative is
saying that like you know unemployment
is just keeping people lazy and keeping
them off and working just like
just like mention the benefits and say
that like it's not actually as
you know reliable uh to like live off of
those conservatives think it is
yeah and there is no evidence that most
people want to earn what you earn on
unemployment and don't work we have a
really rare situation right now because
of the pandemic
and the enhanced unemployment but
generally speaking
people want to work generally speaking
you make more working than on state
unemployment now we have a
again we have an enhanced unemployment
and um
there are some people who would be
satisfied just making unemployment
and and not working but it's very few
many people get meaning from work people
get a connection to other people most
people want to work
period all right thank you very much
this is actually my first time trying to
call in so it means a lot to be able to
speak with you so beautiful for
all the content thanks for the call
appreciate it thank you very much
all right let's hear from a couple of
other people why don't we go to is it
cayenne from queens
hey david yeah that's cayenne how are
you hi
well uh so my first question uh is
related to
how biden is doing um i'm a pretty
uh left progressive and uh one
went by to one i was still kind of
hopeful
there was some talk of him being you
know
having these uh fdr aspirations
yeah but over the past few months i feel
like um
he hasn't really been talking about much
that has been
important to progressives like
climate change healthcare or a minimum
wage just kind of
went out the window disappeared so
i'm one i'm wondering um do you think
he's starting to feel like it's okay
to just abandon uh these
things that are important to the
progressive base and
uh an addition like a similar question
but
different perspective is do you think
he's okay
because americans don't really expect
much
from government i mean uh
they're like okay with just how things
are
and as long as you know they don't have
a an idiot like trump
being that they're just like okay and
they don't expect much and do you think
that's a problem
um so i think that there are lots of
people who
who no longer expect much from
government but the thing we have to be
careful with that
is that there's a political movement
which is all about not expecting stuff
from government and that government
should be doing less
so i think that that's something we sort
of want to be careful of in terms of the
language we use
in terms of biden i mean listen i i
think that i'm not seeing
any u-turns from biden what i am
certainly seeing is he hasn't yet done
all of the things he promised to do he
you know talked about a public option
that hasn't happened there's other
things
he got covet relief passed he
scaled up vaccination now he's working
on infrastructure
if he gets an infrastructure deal done
by september 1st
it will be a pretty significant first
year in terms of major legislation
in conjunction with a lot of the
executive orders that he did early to
undo some of the stuff that donald trump
did
is it a progressive dream no but i never
expected it to be
so i my sense is biden's doing more or
less what i expected and i've not seen
him
abandon anything he claimed he would do
yet
some things he hasn't done yet right so
we have to give him a term to see if he
does it but
i i feel like i'm getting from biden
exactly what i expected
okay yeah i i'm also getting what i
expected
like my mindset and the primaries is
like he's not gonna
do much to satisfy progressives but
i don't know what happened i just had
some weird hope that
uh in the beginning like maybe he's more
progressive than we thought so that was
probably
not a good way for me to think no no i
believed from the beginning that
he was exactly who he said he was during
the campaign and that that's what i'm
seeing so far
yeah so about the second question like
do you think that it's a problem that
americans oh um
you said i should watch my language but
um i just feel like americans are
satisfied they're like
uh you know we're very insular so
you know you have a hard time seeing
that other
countries have uh you know universal
healthcare or free college tuition
um so they're just like okay without
having that as long as
long as everything seems stable i think
there are lots of people
who want those things but after the four
years we had
certainly the standard for just a
minimum that people expect which is like
a president
that sort of seems normal and doesn't
alienate every other country that we're
allied with etc the bar has been dropped
and we are adjusting to that bar being
dropped as that happens
i think it will be perfectly reasonable
to refocus
exactly on the things you're talking
about that are that are more common
in northern european social democracies
so it's not a one or the other it's
we're adjusting to the new normal of
being of having had trump as president
for four years
and i think we're pretty close to being
adjusted and now it's time to get some
stuff done
okay i appreciate your perspective and
thanks for having me on
all right cayenne from queens very much
appreciate the call
that's gonna do it for today as always
sorry i couldn't get to everybody but i
will take more calls again very soon
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right let's get into
audience questions for the week much to
discuss today i got
so many messages about this that i will
talk about it it wasn't part of my
coverage on monday of donald trump's
speech because
it wasn't actually something that
happened but i got so many emails saying
david
is it true that donald trump
wore his pants backwards at that crazy
speech
in north carolina it is not true but the
listen
i understand what's going on trump came
up to the stage
and we're going to show a picture of it
and his pants just looked
strange there were weird creases on the
front it almost looked like there were
like there was no zipper like there was
just a seam and there was speculation
his pants were backwards or it was some
kind of a mermaid outfit or
he was wearing an elastic waistband and
that's why there was no zipper
i have to tell you when i looked at it
closely the wrinkles looked like trump
had just been sitting
and the pants are wrinkly and i do
see what looks like a zipper crease
although it's not
as noticeable maybe as some others would
would imagine it to be
and i didn't for a second think that
donald trump wore his pants backwards
this was then looked at by snopes and
snopes did indeed determine
no trump did not wear his pants backward
at the
rally you asked so we watched the
90-minute speech
um and they found that uh
the photographs simply do not show that
trump's pants were backwards now what's
the the funny thing to me
about this is first of all the idea that
we we many of us would believe
that trump might wear his pants
backwards like that that wouldn't be
beyond the realm of possibility
i would believe it it just happened not
to have been the case
but the more interesting thing was how
low is the bar
that a lot of the commentaries including
my own on twitter when i saw this
were essentially uh listen the speech
was deranged
trump lied throughout it he told
corrosive lies about democracy
he did all of these things but his pants
weren't on backwards
and i think it was lucas grindley from
the
advocate if i recall correctly who
responded to me and said
this is how low the bar now is that we
can say
at least the guy's pants were on
straight
but uh no his pants were forward
i don't really care about donald trump's
clothing
i've never understood from a very just
practical perspective
a guy as wealthy as trump claims to be
or as wealthy as
trump is they're not the same thing but
he's still a wealthy guy
how has no one gone to him and said sir
the full seat suit look is not
in right now the tailored slimmer fit
look is in or maybe they have
and trump doesn't look right in the
slimmer fit suits
i've never understood how a guy this
wealthy has such terrible suits but i
know that
trump's an older guy and that's a style
that
uh there are other older men i know
who still like the full seat suit and
that appears to be trump but his pants
were on forward
uh as far as we can tell david
now that we know more about the ufo uap
revelations of the last month
are you ready to say that the ufos
aren't aliens from another planet
yeah i mean here's the thing i i don't
know how many times i have to say this
i've been asked this so many times when
we talk about
an unidentified flying odd object
or a uap we aren't
implying that the default would be if we
aren't
aware of what a thing is it's aliens
from another planet
and so after the 60 minutes interview
came out with these
uh claims about um these uap
ufos that pilots had seen and uh some of
the documents that the government has
released
and the indication was we we don't know
what this is because it doesn't
match anything that is ours and
it's appearing to defy some of the
constraints of the physical world as we
understand it and so on and so forth
my first explanation isn't these are
aliens that came from somewhere else
and nobody else saw them arrive no other
plan
no other country saw them arrive to the
planet but then
our military pilots see i don't go to
that the simplest explanations to me
include some aspect of this was
distorted by the way that it was filmed
which is one
area of of uh study that is being looked
at
and the idea that certain camera lenses
can make things look as though they are
moving in ways and at speeds
in which they actually aren't that's one
aspect
the other aspect would be these are
foreign elements of some kind from
an adversary and so we are not
um uh we're being given limited
information
and these this is a you know
surveillance of some kind from uh from
an adversary
the third possibility would be this is
u.s
stuff that is so highly classified
that what the government has decided to
do is to allow the pilots to come out
and say what they did but not go any
further and just claim
this is not stuff the us government is
is at least publicly taking credit for
when it actually is some classified
government program and then the fourth
possibility and this is this is like the
cynical one in some
sense uh is that this is all
a disinformation campaign to make other
countries see this stuff and go
oh man they is this do they have this at
the
in the united states is the is are these
actually technologies that the us has
we are way behind let's try to reverse
engineer this for example and the idea
is a disinformation campaign to send
other countries on a wild goose chase to
stuff that's
simply cgi all of those possibilities
strike me as far more likely again just
an occam's razor what requires the
fewest assumptions
those all strike me as far more likely
than these are aliens from some other
part of the universe that have
visited us when i sort of said this is
my position a couple of weeks ago
i got 99 emails from people saying david
thank you this
this just makes sense this seems like
the most plausible
way to understand what we've seen and a
few people saying david
obviously these are aliens from another
planet and everybody's in on the
cover-up and you're part of being in on
the cover-up again
that requires lots of assumptions and
complexity so i tend to lean towards
the simpler explanations now for people
who will write to me and say david
do you think that there are aliens i
think that statistically it's likely
there is intelligent life elsewhere in
the universe
other than earth i just don't think this
is it arriving
call me crazy let me know your thoughts
that's my best
guess as to what this is as of right now
hey david 10 of the trump rioters were
military
doesn't this make trump's coup fantasy a
real possibility
so i think there's a few important
things to talk about here one
is remember anytime we're talking about
a percentage we need to know what the
base rate is
the research i've done shows that seven
percent of the population
is veterans and just under half a
percent of the population
is currently active duty military so
military is was over represented at the
trump riots but not dramatically so
overrepresented but not dramatically so
so active duty and
veterans are 7.4 of the population and
so far 1 in 10 defendants are
military that means that 10 instead of
7.4 percent that's about a 33 percent
over representation of military in the
trump riot
defenders okay good next question
uh could 10 of the military imagine that
10
of the military supported a coup for
donald trump
it's already the wrong math it's already
wrong math
10 of those willing to riot
are members of the military that does
not mean
10 of the military is willing to riot
to try to overthrow joe biden so the
numbers don't
the numbers don't even make sense but
more importantly
because of the military chain of command
even if 10 of the military was willing
able and
interested to participate in some kind
of insurrection to reinstall donald
trump and remove joe biden
it's just not enough it's just not
enough and it's been made
pretty clear and i know that there are
those who say they're just pretending
it's pretty clear that military
leadership
uh would not support anything
like what donald trump claims to be
dreaming up or what what it is claimed
donald trump is dreaming up for august
or whenever it's supposed to be
so i think that there's a concern about
yes the over-representation of military
among the rioters
there's a concern about law enforcement
involvement
as a part of the january six riots
there are concerns that we could again
see violence in august
when again donald trump doesn't become
president of the united states
that's all for for sure no doubt about
it do i think that
even if 10 of the military um
wanted the coup they could make it
happen no i don't and remember it's not
10
of the military are trump coors it's 10
of the rioters are current or former
military so i don't think that this is
actually something
that we have to worry about i think we
have lots to worry about
i think there are concerns about will
things get violent i think there are
concerns about
to what degree will the republican party
continue to use the same rhetoric
that propped up the january 6th
rioters all of those are concerns what
will the most committed q anon trumpus
do
when august comes and goes and again
donald trump is not president of the
united states
i don't have the answers to that but the
military is not going to actually help
donald trump
achieve this if you disagree with me let
me know
uh you can find me on twitter at
deepakman
we've got a great bonus show for you
today you can get instant access to the
bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
or by becoming a patron
at patreon.com david pacman show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman